like you take everything you just
described
how much how many more layers of
difficulty has been has been added on
with kovid i was gonna ask this and uh
having to do things remotely because
that sounds like a nightmare in person
yeah yeah um yeah there's a reason that
if you see me like in the room i'm like
a sweaty mess because it is like super
intensive right um in the in this like
in the covert times
uh it's been interesting because
depending on where you are it's actually
a little more convenient in terms of the
time difference because obviously it's
like so far in front of everywhere so
yeah um if you're recording in america
it's quite nice because you you know
it's sort of like an early morning thing
and i became a bit of an early rise
agent covered yeah at least for a time
until something was very not an early
rise but um uh in europe it's kind of
interesting we did a lot of recording in
prague
some budapest
doing pandemic and uh for an upcoming
project we did a little recording in
america as well right um yeah uh
normally for
um
for europe it's normally like an
australian nighttime sort of recording
so yeah yeah you kind of sit down at
like seven eight o'clock at night and
then you do six seven hours so you kind
of finish like two three o'clock in the
morning so you're on call yeah with
people who are just in a big hall yeah
so basically just stream the audio on
audio movers and zoom wow yeah it's
actually to be honest like it's actually
not bad really yeah but what if it like
lags halfway through like a recording
right yeah
yeah because it's like a [ __ ] classic
australian internet just crashes yeah
yeah yeah i was about to say it must be
[ __ ] yeah it's like because yeah
[ __ ] it's like oh kevin's connecting
yeah yeah
it's like why is our conductor in like
four like 480p like yeah i can barely
see him like at that point you're not
conducting a board yeah yeah
that was what was really nice about like
going back to sydney for a couple of
projects sorry going back to sydney
going to send me a couple of projects uh
because like yeah melvin said he's like
an hour and a half on the plane and
stuff right that's pretty cool but um
yeah to finally get back to conducting
for uh for star wars was really cool
because that was the first time i've
done it i
forgot
the like because the muscles just like
just like go away
yeah because like try doing this
yeah for like nine hours right yeah yeah
it's very like just the right just right
you're like quagmire
is
[Laughter]
uh
yeah i forgot how like physically
intensive it was just like because um
because what you normally meant to do is
like maybe be a little bit reserved in
like moving your arms
yeah like quite a few hours jesus yeah
yeah it's a little interesting sounds
really intense yeah so like speaking of
oh sorry i don't know i have nothing of
value to say
some of the biggest shows in like the
past few years i literally have nothing
about you to say
yes
so star wars yeah how was how was that
like really cool
how did like
how was it like the news came in to be
like uh can you compose a piece of like
music for star wars media because i'm
assuming like what great honor
you know obviously it has the history of
history yeah um and just to be able to
kind of obviously so star wars visions
is uh an animated um series based in the
universe star wars and i did one of
those one of those um episodes
did the the episode four called village
bride right and um what i really liked
about it is that um star wars visions uh
our episode explored like some really
cool like spiritual um and uh biblical
shuffles
i was waiting for that word
it explored some really nice concepts
with the force uh which was just i mean
i grew up watching that yeah yeah yeah
you watched the original trilogy with my
dad and then then my dad and i watched
the the prequels and then they did watch
the sequels as well of course but um
yeah it was it was really
uh it was really nice to sort of have
like one hand in like sort of that
aesthetic world at the same time we're
exploring
uh certain like spiritual aspects
especially considering like the the
backdrop is is um it's very like sort of
kyoto-esque yeah yeah yeah so like to
have um
to have like the ability to use like
traditional japanese instruments so we
use uh show
we use koto we use shakati and
those in tokyo recorded um orchestra in
sydney put them all together uh but to
especially especially the
the show is is a is a wow
is the mouth organ it's a it's it's a so
i mean i'm i'm very very oversimplifying
to say that they've never heard of this
yeah yeah i know yeah i know
and then when kevin said it's a mouth
organ i was this close to being like no
it's not
so you blow into a small like a giant
amount sort of like giant amount thanks
kevin giant amount giant a large amount
a large amount of um
bamboo pipes
you've definitely seen it before right
yeah it's a
it's part of a temple culture a lot i've
never heard about that
i mean you would have heard it
but um it's like 12 to 14 sort of um
uh individual little pipes right into it
you can blow in and and like blow in and
out right uh to create uh
sort of a very very yeah this thing this
thing have you seen this thing oh i've
seen that yeah yeah
yeah yeah i have seen this yeah yeah so
it's a very complex very beautiful sort
of uh cluster of notes that create a
very very dense very specific core and
all these chords have very very very
special meaning so first off obviously
you know as an australian you got i
really really wanted to be very careful
about that and you know that there's
been um i mean there's always a bit of
an attitude in australia when it comes
to
uh using um australia's indigenous
instruments which is uh you
you that you don't want to [ __ ] this up
you don't want to be that person that
has really disrespected a very very
important and very sacred instrument
yeah and so that mentality i've carried
like i've been lucky enough to use
uh
like sort of australian instruments in
the past and it's always been in very um
explicit collaboration with um first
nations people and using those
instruments because i'm not going to use
that instrument on my own yeah i feel
like i have the
necessary i don't
yeah and so
even though i am australian uh i would i
want to make sure that when it comes to
japan's instruments it's the exact same
approach yeah yeah very very like
it in a good way like sort of you know
talk to the musicians saying what is
okay what isn't okay what are you happy
with are you not happy with what is
natural what is unnatural those sorts of
things what do you have thankfully like
the musician especially the show player
um is phenomenal yeah and was very very
very open to just sort of discussing
okay what does and doesn't work these
are chords like these are sort of like
the um the core chords yeah that you
can't like that that you know come on
like the
yeah it has like different systems it's
very very interesting so you um
it it basically you you have like
different combinations of notes that
um they have like a different kanji and
it works actually on the circle it works
on a
not a pendulum sorry but like a circle
of fifths type of thing yeah but not
first circle of chords but then all of
them have different meanings and stuff
like that um i really hope they're not
bastardizing us as well but like
what i wouldn't know no no
probably i know
i don't know no no but um basically what
happens if we did a lot of work shopping
and just said okay how do we make sure
that like is this good this is okay
right okay right and when sort of thing
yeah is that like sorry because excuse
me on this you're saying like is that
good as in like if if you were to use it
incorrectly it would be disrespectful
well it might not like i don't know but
the problem is i don't know right right
and i'd rather like you don't want to
overstep the boundary just in case yeah
i'd rather ask too many questions and
just like yeah yeah right
be just said no don't worry about it
it's great yeah don't worry about it but
that's not my permission to give yeah
yeah once i've received it then i feel
okay let's now that now we can record
now we can actually you know work with
these instruments and obviously like
being commissioned to do something which
is anime obviously star wars as well but
like
doing something that is anime yeah um
and in this case has a very specific
relationship to uh japan and its
instruments that's super important for
me to make sure that like you know i get
that right yeah
wanna yeah i don't wanna i don't wanna
[ __ ] it up yeah of course
yeah is it is it is there ever like a
a
difficulty when you're working on a
property
that has had so much
history and previous works that you
could kind of
get lost in inspiration with yeah i mean
yeah it's not it's it's not an easy one
right yeah
it starts a lot of music right yeah yeah
yeah yeah he's like there's a lot of the
best music yeah so
because i guess you're just like
naturally going to be compared to the
likes of like john williams right that's
like
yeah but you don't want to sound too
much like that yeah yeah it's like
because you have listened to it there's
no way you yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah but um like
i mean thankfully because it's animated
actually
it actually because it's not live action
you actually we almost in a way had a
little bit more freedom yeah because we
were trying something new and that was
one of the ethos you felt you thought
ethos
[Music]
that was one of the um sort of the the
core sort of yeah yeah um concepts of of
the show was to you know obviously be in
the universe but then to explore it in
this
in in a medium that you know i've been
not only lucky enough to be part of but
i really do genuinely love it yeah yeah
yeah it's important yeah yeah because
like i remember like watching that
episode and i was like of course i got
to support my boy kevin i'm gonna watch
star wars visions and i remember like
going to this episode and i was just
like this is like definitely star wars
but this is like such a kevin star wars
i'm like i don't know like i'm not like
well-versed enough in like musical lingo
to be able to like break down what makes
a kevin star wars it just felt like a
kevin star wars like kevin take on the
star wars
you know universe and just you know the
iconic music as well is that something
you do unconsciously like you have a
kind of a signature almost to your music
that's a good question i'm not actually
even sure like you know i think
regardless of whether you like aim to do
it or not i think you've achieved it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah do you
think that when people listen to your
music without knowing you'd like or they
have heard your previous works they can
identify yeah another one of your work
yeah because actually i didn't even know
that you did the music for that episode
but as soon as like the the episode
started playing i'm like this is kevin i
i
know i know my boy yeah um i may
gravitate towards certain cluster
courses but
yeah
i don't know like um
i like i
i wouldn't know how to put my finger on
it yeah i wouldn't know how to do that
but um
i think in a way like it's both a very
endearing thing to hear and at the same
time i'm like okay how could i how could
i knock it yeah how could i not how can
i not do that
surprise for the [ __ ]
how can i do that how can i do it next
year so it's almost like no it's like
it's it's a great thing to hear and i am
happy to hear it at the same time i'm
like okay i will i do eventually want to
feel like it sounds a bit [ __ ] wanky
but like i want to evolve yeah yeah of
course
that's too far
you get a little bit too biblical man
well i mean one might have to evolve and
every year every year of course of
course yeah
yeah i mean because
as as i we were mentioning before i just
turned 30 and so i've started like
putting together like a list of okay
what do i want to do in like the next
10 years like what do i want to do
between 30 and 40. and one of them is
like just to like i want to learn to
sing again because i used to sing and i
used to not be totally [ __ ] at it and
now i just i know i sound like pretty
sure like if like get out of practice
yeah let's just say if like the cat was
angry and screeched it would still sound
better than
what my uh what my voice
to find out
no like
like singing and i want to like kind of
try a few different musical ideas i want
i would be really nice to do like a
personal album first time like i've
never really released like like a
personal album like music right
it's been like for the last you know
as far as i can remember like in terms
of my professional life it's always been
to a project which is [ __ ] awesome
but at the same time i feel like you
know what in the next 10 years it'll be
good to like really create something
like that's just you yeah yeah yeah me i
gotta figure out what that is as well
because like i don't i don't know what i
am so welcome to being in your thirties
[ __ ]
okay good luck
that's like like that you know that's
really respectable though like i think
as you know because all of us right now
are in kind of the creative field
regardless of if it's different types of
creative feels like i think we can all
you know kind of
you know empathize with that like
feeling right like yeah you know you
want to
get yourself out there and try and
spread your wings out as much as
possible creatively right i mean look
how much you've grown as well like look
at your channel and look at your content
how it's developed i don't know all
three of you
i mean like look at this podcast i mean
last time we caught up we it didn't
exist and now it is this your personal
channels as well we watch them all the
time and it's like we watch the old
content watch the new stuff it's it's i
mean all of it's great but it is so so
lovely to see how it has changed in the
world yeah likewise man likewise thank
you likewise with your stuff oh yeah
i'm so sorry